we are at the waterworks Museum in
Chestnut Hill here in Boston which is an
amazing place filled with the machines
that made Boston sanitary in the 1800s
what you're looking at here is probably
the greatest innovation affecting health
in the US and around the world in three
centuries clean water more than
penicillin more than more than any form
of the heart surgery if you look in the
data there's a golden age of mortality
reductions in the late 19th century
early in the 20th century where
mortality fell more rapidly than at any
period in American history most of what
was killing people was infectious
disease and more so in cities than and
much more so in cities infectious
disease spreads from person to person so
the denser is the population the more
there's the danger the leading cause of
death at the time was tuberculosis which
is primarily airborne but the second
leading cause of death or causey is were
really waterborne disease cholera
typhoid fever a whole host of bacteria
that would live in the water and would
circulate through from human waste into
groundwater or into streams and rivers
and that would then be used for drinking
and then people would die people would
die and so throughout the 19th and the
20th centuries you had immense outbreaks
of infectious diseases in City after
city roughly every decade or so you'd
see this big outbreak of disease now
this water works mania that that made
our cities far from infecting our cities
it disinfected our cities begins with a
mistake right it begins with a disease
that is not in fact waterborne but that
led to a watering Commission in
Philadelphia in the seventeen
yellow fever which we now think of as a
tropical disease in low-income countries
where it still is yellow fever was no
prominent in areas of the US that got
very hot and had lots of mosquitoes but
the good thing that comes from it is
that Philadelphia decides to build a
waterworks mm-hmm
so they hire Benjamin Latrobe for P of
British nationality who goes on to build
the capital in the US and Philadelphia
sets up the first clean water system
what you wonder the giving proof - one
of the things that you need you need a
kind of engineering class that can go
ahead and do it so an engineering class
that can bring this mammoth construction
to bear to improve the people's health
this is the great wave of engineering
one of the great waves of engineering so
this is sanitation engineers and
environmental engineers and people who
learn how to transport water 20 miles in
the case of Boston 40 miles in the case
of New York get clean water to cities
there interestingly there are all public
employees so they all get hired by the
public sector they get taken out of the
political process which fights for
decades and decades over how we're going
to get water where we're going to get
water and they bring sort of a
professional class they start their own
journals the Journal of the American
Water Works Association and the Water
Works Journal and so on and they're
communicating with each other and
they're they're basically cleaning up
America cities and are they typically
independent agencies independent
entities or they often they're
independent agencies typically they
would get some operational money from
supplying the water so often on an
ongoing basis they would do that but the
actual construction of the water works
is very very involved to give you a
sense in 1915 the typical American city
has more invested in their water
facilities
they're cleaning and pumping facilities
than an entire years worth of city
revenue so actually getting the money to
do this is a big deal you have to
understand you wanted the political
process has to figure out where the
water is and how are they going to get
it part of the Sanitation problem is
bringing the water in but the other part
is getting the waste getting the waste
out so sewers happen somewhat at the
same time somewhat later and they have
somewhat similar but also somewhat
distinct issues right the sewers are the
complimentary technology yes so you need
to get the clean water in and you need
to get the dirty water away and you need
to treat it and do all sorts of things
and you need to make sure that you're
not dumping your sewer into some other
body down the river right so the sewer
technology improves as well you know the
there are stories about the early sewers
and again many of these were the sort of
private companies the early sewers that
were not big enough for the areas they
were serving and so whenever you had a
big rainstorm they would be like
cesspools and they would back up yeah it
still happens in Cambridge and so the
streets would become just kind of big
sewers and so you had to have the
complementary technology to to sort of
dig up everything and to put the huge
sewer pipes in the sewer drains
everywhere and to drain it from
individual houses remember this a period
of time where were invented where we're
inventing these sort of indoor toilet
indoor water closet so no more outhouses
and
outdoor waste so that's actually another
very big technological issue and how did
they pay for all of this how did how did
the finance of his work you can imagine
with the series of corrupt legislators
Laura we could get out of hand before so
you go through waves where cities would
build up debt and then they would
default on the debt and so right and so
you have to actually develop a system to
do that
that's probably why that's one of the
reasons why the first big Water Works
are in big cities New York Philadelphia
Boston New Orleans all of these cities
which were big and had it ready are
access to capital before you get into
the smaller cities that are going to be
defaulting on debt and for whom it's
difficult to know how they're going to
pay back and I'm always struck that New
York had the salutary example of the
Erie Canal that it occurred maybe
fifteen years before the crow from a
products which was also debt financed
and it worked out marvelously well when
you have the people when you have the
engineering talent and you can do it you
can do amazing things and so this is an
era where there are lots of great things
being done even at a period of time that
we think of as sort of the height of
corruption of local municipal state and
city governments
you